yeah hello and welcome to this  announcement for today's live shows on  Ches 24th we are well anyway we are  doing this at the same time as last week  at 4:30 Central Europe in time for the  German show and then the English or 90  minutes later due to the single cup  today there's the final round of the of  the tournament and in fact it is rather  interesting because there's five six  seven players so theoretically at least  could still win the event even Magnus  again in the race after having a win  yesterday anyway so it's going to be  interesting to watch tonight and  therefore we have reschedule to my shows  to be the opener basically starting at  4:30 so if you can manage the length the  links are in the description thank you  very much